sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
morgen ist der welttag gegen
kinderarbeit und die berichte der
internationalen arbeitsorganisation und
von unicef sind alarmierend übrigens
gerade verschärft auch durch die
weltweite hungerkrise 160 millionen
kinder auf der welt sind zu kinderarbeit
verdammt die hälfte arbeitet unter
besonders ausbeuterischen und
gefährlichen bedingungen
aber meine damen und herren wir sind uns
sicherlich alle einig kinder auf der
welt die gehören in schulen statt in
minen sie gehören in schulen und mit
ihren klassenkameraden zusammen mit in
textilfabriken und sie sollen auch nicht
auf feldern schuften
deshalb müssen wir unserer verantwortung
gerecht werden als staaten aber auch als
volkswirtschaften unseren beitrag zu
leisten dass wir überall kinderarbeit
auf der welt entschieden bekämpfen und
dafür ist dieses lieferketten gesetzt
ein ganz ganz wichtiger schritt
meine damen und herren anstand und
wohlstand das darf kein gegensatz sein
und anständige unternehmer die sich
kümmern dürfen keinen nachteil auch kein
wettbewerbsnachteil dazu haben gegenüber
dem die sich in ihren zu die fakten
nicht kümmern und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir heute mit dem lieferketten
gesetz klare standards für alle
unternehmen in deutschland schaffen sich
zu kümmern im kampf gegen ausbeutung
kinderarbeit oder sklavenarbeit magath
an
ich bin sehr dankbar den
koalitionsfraktionen
das ist nach hartem ringen hinter
koalition und das ist ja kein geheimnis
dass man von gerd müller und ich
gemeinsam gekämpft haben für ein
robustes gesetz 1 dass kein papiertiger
ist sondern dass auch zähne hat das auch
folgen hat wenn man sich nicht kümmert
mit einer robusten örtlichen durch
situation mit dem zweifelsfall auch
schmerzhaften zwangs und ordnungsgeldern
mit der möglichkeit unternehmen die sich
nicht kümmern von der öffentlichen
auftragsvergabe ausschnitte sind und was
uns sehr wichtig war dass wir die
rechtsposition der menschen die
tatsächlich von
menschenrechtsverletzungen getroffen
sind verstärken und verbessern die haben
heute schon vor zivilgerichten in
deutschland die möglichkeiten zu klagen
aber seien wir ehrlich das sind meistens
sehr arme menschen die wenn sie ihren
menschenrechten verletzt werden nicht
die power nicht das geld die möglichkeit
haben vor ein deutsches gericht zu
ziehen
es wird mit diesem gesetz zukünftig
möglich sein dass deutsche
gewerkschaften in deutschland nicht
regierungsorganisationen im namen und
mit zustimmung der betroffenen
menschenrechte einklagen können das ist
konkreter menschenrechtsschutz meine
damen und herren der dieses gesetz auch
mit sich
der nach zähem ringen auch den
koalitionsfraktionen und ich weiß vielen
in der cdu csu uns das nicht leicht
gefallen sehr sehr dankbar dass wir
dieses gesetz im parlamentarischen
verfahren noch verbessert haben
beispielsweise indem auch ausländische
unternehmen einbezogen werden die
größere niederlassung und
beschäftigtenzahlen in deutschland haben
also nicht nur adidas sondern auch nike
und meine damen und herren es ist auch
gelungen die mitbestimmungsrechte von
betriebsräten in solchen prozessen zu
stärken dass verstärkt dieses gesetz
zusätzlich meine damen und herren wir
haben wir haben mit diesem lieferketten
gesetz heute eine möglichkeit ein stück
rechtsgeschichte zu schreiben wir haben
die möglichkeit auch ein starkes signal
an die europäische union zu geben denn
wir wollen eine europäische lösung im
sinne auch von gleichen
wettbewerbsbedingungen aber er vor allen
dingen weil wir als europäer europäer
unseren beitrag leisten wollten für eine
gerechtere gestaltung der globalisierung
gerd müller und ich waren 2009/10 in den
tropen
wir haben erlebt was passieren kann wenn
unternehmen sich kümmern wir haben
positive beispiele gesehen
textilfabriken in denen menschen
anständig behandelt wurden in dem es nur
mitarbeitervertretungen des
arbeitsschutz gehabt gesunde
arbeitsbedingungen und einigermaßen
angemessene löhne und wie hat das krasse
gegenteil gesehen eine gabe reihen der
frauen ausgebeutet wurden bis zu den
knien in chemikalien standen meine damen
und herren ich sage es nochmal unseren
wohlstand können wir nicht dauerhaft auf
der ausbeutung von menschen aufbauen und
deshalb ist das ein ganz wichtiger
schritt für dem ich diesem parlament
sehr dankbar
meine damen und herren dieses
lieferketten gesetz sondern heute in
dieser deutsche bundestag beschließen
und ich bin sehr sehr dankbar sie gesagt
denjenigen die sich engagiert haben
vielen parlamentariern meiner eigenen
fraktion auch den berichterstatterin
berichterstatter des koalitionspartners
namentlich auch hermann hohl ganz
persönlich aber vor allen dingen danke
ich den gewerkschaften
nichtregierungsorganisationen den
kirchen und vielen bürgerinnen und
bürgern die dafür gesorgt haben dass das
heute möglich war mit ihrem druck und
mit ihrem engagement herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
soweit der arbeitsminister hubertus heil
der hier nochmal das lieferketten gesetz
vorgestellt und verteidigt da training
springer jetzt von der afg der erste
redner zu diesem punkt in dieser debatte
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir debattieren die
heute morgen über das so genannte
lieferketten gesetz worum geht es dabei
mit dem lieferketten gesetz will die
bundesregierung unternehmen quasi
staatliche aufgaben übertragen
sie sollen zukünftig innerhalb ihrer
lieferkette bei ihren zulieferern und
deren zulieferern
die einhaltung von umweltstandards
menschenrechtsstandards und
sozialstandards standards durchsetzen
in der gesamten lieferkette weltweit was
staaten und die internationale
gemeinschaft in jahrzehnten nicht
gelungen ist sollen deutsche unternehmen
nun richten
am deutschen wesen soll also wieder
einmal die welt genesen
meine damen und herren wie sieht das
eigentlich in der praxis aus nehmen wir
mal den automobilzulieferer continental
der verfügt über 100 produktionsstätten
hat 5000 liter 5700 lieferanten und die
wiederum haben zulieferer insgesamt
verbaut continental 157 milliarden
produktkomponenten und die werden in
aller welt produziert unter
verschiedenen standards und diese
standards soll das unternehmen nun im
blick behalten
und wer das nicht schafft im blick zu
behalten dem drohen empfindliche strafen
es wurde ja auch gerade schon erwähnt
und schlimmer noch über die eingeführte
prozessstandschaft ist es nun möglich
dass gewerkschaften und ngo s betroffene
in diesen ländern vor deutschen
gerichten vertreten können
dass es dabei unter umständen auch zu
missbräuchlichen und medienwirksamen
klagen kommen kann die deutschen
unternehmen schaden
das wird hier komplett ausgeblendet
meine damen und herren das ist ein
gesetz ein schlechtes gesetz für
deutsche unternehmen ist ein schlechtes
gesetz für deutschland dass ein gesetz
über das sich nur die konkurrenz freut
und die freut sich gleich doppelt denn
das gesetz gilt nur für unternehmen
hören sie lieber zu das gesetz gilt nur
für unternehmen mit hauptsitz in
deutschland chinesische staatsfirmen und
die amerikanische am online plattform
amazon die über rechtlich unselbständige
zweigstellen in deutschland geschäfte
machen die höre ich in der ferne und
beifallklatschen das einstige das
institut für weltwirtschaft warnt vor
konsequenzen wenn dieses gesetz
eingeführt wird es warnt davor dass
deutsche unternehmen abwandern um ihre
wettbewerbsnachteile auszugleichen
großbritannien und die schweiz sind
nicht weit entfernt
das institut waren vor
arbeitsplatzverlusten und damit
einhergehend vor sinkenden
steuereinnahmen
aber es passiert noch etwas anderes
unternehmen würden sich aus
problemregionen zurückziehen mit einer
dramatischen konsequenz denn die lücke
die deutsche unternehmen dort
hinterlassen werden von ausländischen
unternehmen dann gefüllt unternehmen die
weniger wert legen auf menschenrechte
und sozialstandards und ökologische
standards
die folge wäre eine verschlechterung der
menschenrechtslage in diesen ländern
und ich sage ihnen
ein gesetz das zur verschlechterung von
menschenrechts lagen führt das werden
wir als afd nicht unterstützen
und wie immer bei der bundesregierung
wird im gesetzentwurf geschrieben es
gebe keine alternativen dabei gibt es
die
es gibt sogenannte positivliste auf die
man sich mit europäischen partnern
verständigen könnte
darauf stünden den staaten und
unternehmen mit denen das handeln und
problematisch ist es gibt negativlisten
auf denen unternehmen stehen mit denen
man nicht handeln sollte wo es ein
handelsverbot geben sollte die usa
wenden das an und es gibt das instrument
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
entwicklungshilfe und wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit um staaten in ihrer
entwicklung zu helfen
davon würden die staaten profitieren
davon würden deutsche unternehmen
profitieren und nicht zuletzt
deutschland
meine damen und herren zum letzten punkt
entwicklungszusammenarbeit hat die auch
die fraktion zwei vorträge zwei anträge
vorgelegt meiner kollegen markus maier
und dietmar friedhof ich bin aber sicher
dass sie die anträge ablehnen werden
nicht weil sie schlecht sind sondern
weil sie von der alternative für
deutschland sind so ist das hier mit den
demokratischen sogenannten
demokratischen parteien im deutschen
bundestag ich danke ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der bundesminister
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit dr
gerd müller
herr präsident meine damen und herren
nie wieder
reiner plasa das hat mir den mut gegeben
und auch die kraft mein besuch an den
trümmern in bangladesch vor sieben
jahren nie wieder ran blaser das war das
versprechen an 1100 frauen die gestorben
sind weil grundlegende bedingungen der
arbeitssicherheit nicht eingehalten
worden und heute acht jahre und danach
hatten acht jahre gedauert sage ich wir
haben euch nicht vergessen wir haben
nicht vergessen denn heute kommt dieses
lieferketten gesetz ein starkes ein
starkes signal und ein wichtiger schritt
zur durchsetzung grundlegende
menschenrechtsstandards in globalen
lieferketten wobei das heil angesprochen
heute früh millionen hunderte millionen
von kindern nämlich zur schule gehen
sondern in miedern arbeiten in
steinbrüchen arbeiten der auf plantagen
damit wir unseren kaffee trinken können
dieses lieferketten gesetz liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das war
teamwork gegen extrem starkes lobbying
und gegen extrem starkes lobbying und
ich sage aber auch wenn ich in die
reihen der koalitionsfraktionen schaue
ich schließe auch die grünen mit einem
es war aber auch für viele viele viele
herzens arbeit für viele kolleginnen und
kollegen herzens arbeit und dann nämlich
werden kofler stellvertreten als
menschenrechtsbeauftragte maria
flachsbarth bei uns claudia roth bei den
grünen die das mit sozusagen zu ihrer
politischen lebensaufgabe schon viele
viele jahre und jahrzehnte gemacht haben
herr bundesminister gestanden sie ein
zwischenfall dieser art seien gange und
dafür meinen dank und meinen respekt
christ und sozialdemokraten peter
altmaier unser wirtschaftsminister und
hubertus heil die kanzlerin und olaf
scholz hermann gröhe
die berichterstatterin und
berichterstatter peter weiss ich müsste
jetzt viele auf ziemlich sagen noch
einmal das schafft nicht einer oder drei
minister sondern das schafft nur eine
starke koalitionsfraktionen die den
willen haben hier etwas zu ändern
und eigentlich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen kann keiner dagegen sagen hier
im haus es muss noch mehr passieren
okay das ist auch meine meinung und
deshalb dürfen wir nicht wegschauen und
ich sage ihnen für christ und
sozialdemokraten geht die goldene regel
für ethisch moralisches handeln zu hause
und weltweit
und diese goldene regel wie haben wir
alle auch schon im kindergarten gelernt
was du nicht willst das man dir tu das
füg auch keinem anderen zu und diesen
spruch möchte ich auch in den büros der
arbeitgeberpräsidenten und verbände in
deutschland hängen zählen
was du nicht willst das man dir tu das
füg auch keinem anderen zu
in bangladesch oder in äthiopien am
anfang der lieferkette
dieses gesetz ist ein zentraler baustein
auf dem weg zu einer gerechteren
globalisierung und es müssen weitere
folgen
eine europäische regelung eine
neufassung der welthandels ordnung nicht
frei sondern fairer welthandel
ökonomische ökologische und soziale
mindeststandards und dazu brauchen wir
nicht mehr und nicht weniger
nach gaap von der wto eine neue wto
meine damen und herren kolleginnen und
kollegen das war vielleicht meine letzte
rede hier aber ganz sicher das
wichtigste gesetz für mehr gerechtigkeit
zwischen reich und arm
wir haben noch viel zu tun herbsleben
dank ein sehr zufriedener erklärt müller
in der tat er wird auch nicht in den
neuen bundestag zurückkehren er hatte
wie kaum ein anderer für dieses
lieferketten gesetzt gekämpft auch gegen
widerstände in den eigenen reihen mit
dem lieferketten gesetzt sollen ja
kinder und zwangsarbeit sowie miserable
arbeitsbedingungen ebenso eingedämmt
werden wie die umweltzerstörung bei der
produktion und hier viel applaus der
kollegen für die entscheidenden
bundesminister gerd müller
der bundestag debattiert über das
lieferketten gesetz zweite und dritte
lesung und der nächste redner kung von
der fdp karl julius kronberg ist er ist
im ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
absolute armut in der welt sinkt da 30
jahren kontinuierlich gott sei dank 100
millionen menschen sind in lohn und brot
gekommen ihre lebensbedingungen haben
sich dramatisch verbessert diesem
fortschritt verdanken wir nicht wohl
gemeinten gesetzen hier sondern handel
und investitionen in der welt und dazu
haben gerade deutsche unternehmen
erheblich beigetragen das sollten sie
anerkennen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der koalition
sie haben vollkommen recht es gibt zu
viele viel zu vielen verletzungen
fundamentaler rechte zu viel
kinderarbeit in viel zu vielen ländern
und regionen dieser welt
deshalb ist und bleibt es die aufgabe
der bundesregierung an erster stelle
sich mit allen mitteln für die stärkung
der menschenrechte einzusetzen
aber bitte machen sie sich keinen
schlanken fuß in dem sie die
menschenrechtliche verantwortung auch
die unternehmen abwälzen
welche botschaft wird eigentlich in dem
präsidenten palästen des globalen südens
ankommen dass sie die wirtschaft in
haftung nehmen weil ihre
menschenrechtspolitik ein stumpfes
schwert geblieben ist ihr gesetz liefert
doch geradezu den vorwand dafür dass
sich zustände nicht da besser an wo
staaten ihre erst verantwortung nicht
gerecht werden und das kritisieren wir
sicher sicher ist dagegen dass neue
dokumentationspflichten zusätzliche
bürokratie schaffen es ist schlimm genug
aber nicht das hauptproblem
vielmehr können unbestimmte rechts und
reputationsrisiken zum rückzug aus
problemregionen führen dann wird es
richtig schlecht und zwar für die
ärmsten der armen zuallererst rückzug
halten die wissenschaftlichen dienste
des bundestags in hinblick auf die
chinesische provinz xinjiang für
angezeigt wenn das gesetz kommt lieber
minister
eigentlich ihr landesvorsitzender stefan
weil vw aufsichtsrat und
ministerpräsident in niedersachsen damit
umgehen empfiehlt er die schließung des
vw werks in china sowie die
wissenschaftlichen dienstes raten
das gefährt ist das gesamte china
geschäft von vw und damit zig tausende
arbeitsplätze in deutschland oder oder
wird man sich in begleitung der
parteifunktionäre der kp vor ort
darlegen lassen dass uiguren in
weiterbildungs camps und nicht in
umerziehungslager sitzen dann liefert
ihr gesetzt die grundlage für
chinesische propaganda das sind im gang
die welt in ordnung ist vw höchstselbst
hättet das seiner gesetzlichen
sorgfaltspflicht genügend festgestellt
wie zynisch ist denn das liebe kollegin
und boni aussenpolitik außenpolitik
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
wirtschaft müssen geschlossen für unsere
werte kämpfen und zwar zusammen da wo
menschenrechte verletzt werden und nicht
gegeneinander vor deutschen gerichten
ein kluges gesetz schreckt nicht ab
motiviert die anständigen zu mehr
handeln und mehr auslandsinvestitionen
ein kluges gesetz ist europäisch es
erkennt branche initiativen anschafft
safe harbor lösungen für meine
doppelstrukturen liefert negativlisten
die unternehmen helfen risiken zu
erkennen und einzudämmen all das steht
im fdp-antrag ihre sätze liefert es
nicht das wird den eigenen
menschenrechtlichen ansprüchen nicht
gerecht ihr meilenstein brot zum
mühlstein zu werden wir lehnen ab
carius kronberg mit der haltung der fdp
die also dieses gesetz so nicht
mittragen will
die nächste rednerin kommt von der
linken eva maria schreiber
sie ist auch vom ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung
präsident kolleginnen und kollegen
geehrten minister müller anteil ist wohl
sehr selten dass die linke sich mit
herzblut für einen gesetzesentwurf der
regierung eingesetzt hat wir haben es
diesmal getan für ein starkes die
facetten gesetzt um die menschen zu
schützen die für uns in afrika oder
südamerika oder bananen ernten oder in
asien kleider nähen heute endlich zehn
jahre nach einführung der un bleibt
prinzipien für wirtschaft und
menschenrechte stimmen wir darüber ab
minister hahn sie sprechen vom stärksten
gesetz europas und sie minister müller
von einem meilenstein zur durchsetzung
der menschenrechte in globalen
lieferketten
leider ist das in meinen augen nur die
verpackung
denn inhaltlich stimmen wir heute über
ein gesetzesentwurf ab der mit ihrem
ursprünglichen sehr guten entwurf nicht
mehr viel zu tun hat und die
verantwortung dafür trägt der
wirtschaftsflügel der cdu als
verlängerter arm der industrie und
arbeitgeberverbände in den 6
anderthalb jahren erlebten wir ein
internet so aus verzögerung verschiebung
blockade und verbesserung
kanzlerin merkel und minister altmaier
haben sich permanent auf höchster ebene
mit den unternehmensverbänden getroffen
von solchen exklusiven terminen konnten
menschenrechtsverteidiger gewerkschaften
oder die zivilgesellschaft nur träumen
kein wunder dass dieses gesetz nur noch
ein blasser schatten dessen ist was es
ursprünglich einmal war und was es sein
könnte und das lassen wir ihnen nicht
durchgehen
dabei brauchen wir ein starkes gesetz
denn schwere menschenrechtsverstöße sind
noch immer alltäglich in lieferketten
ich denke beispielsweise an kinderarbeit
war kakaoanbau in westafrika oder nehmen
wir die katastrophe vom roma senioren
brasilien im jahr 2009 10 ihr
bescheinigte der tüv süd die stabilität
eines staudamms obwohl die menge bekannt
war der damm brach 272 menschen starben
ein starkes lieferketten gesetz hätte
deren tod womöglich verhindert aber ob
das gesetz einen substanziellen beitrag
zum schutz von menschenrechten und
umwelt leisten wird das werden wir sehen
zu groß ist seine lippen diesem erstens
fehlt eine zivilrechtliche haftung
zweitens wird nicht einmal eines von
tausend unternehmen von der regelung
betroffen
drittens gelten für plantagen oder minen
also die teile der lieferketten wo die
meisten menschenrechtsverletzungen
passieren eben keine vollumfänglichen
sorgfaltspflichten von anfang an
und viertens sucht man ideen wie klima
oder geschlechtergerechtigkeit
vergeblich trotzdem wenn man es sehr
wohlwollend mainz und das meine ich
könnte man von einem ersten kleinen aber
wichtigen schritt von der freiwilligkeit
zur verbindlichkeit sprechen
und deswegen werden wir das gesetz nicht
ablehnen
aber wegen der lücken können wir
bemessen werden auch nicht zustimmen wir
werden uns enthalten
eva maria schreiber für die
linksfraktion die in nächste rednerin in
der debatte ist einziger bürger von
bündnis 90 die grünen
sie ist stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der bündnisgrünen
die ja heute abend ihren parteitag
starten alles bei phoenix zu erleben
ab 17 uhr 15 die berichterstattung des
parteitages hier live bei phoenix der
wirtschaftsflügel der union
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und vor
allem wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
haben in den letzten jahren so einiges
versucht um das lieferketten gesetz zu
blockieren und abzusprechen
es spricht wirklich bände wie sich ein
mächtiger teil der union dagegen wehrt
dass menschenrechte und klimaschutz in
der wirtschafts und handelspolitik
endlich die bedeutung bekommen die sie
verdienen viele menschen aus der
zivilgesellschaft aus den kirchen aus
den gewerkschaften die eu kommission das
eu-parlament und andere staaten minister
müller minister hey viele kolleginnen
und kollegen aus spd aus linkspartei und
auch wir grüne haben eine andere
auffassung als große teile der union und
sind überzeugt ausbeutung und
umweltverschmutzung darf kein
wettbewerbsvorteil mehr sein so viele
produkte
werden längst global hergestellt der
unmittelbaren blick in den einkaufskorb
auf dem bad nicht aber auch
menschenrechtsverletzungen drinliegen
ein wirksames lieferketten gesetz würde
hier abhilfe schaffen
dabei muss ein prinzip immer gelten wenn
globale herstellt und handelt darf sich
gewalt nicht aus der verantwortung
stehlen
das lieferketten gesetzt ist dabei ein
sehr wichtiger wenn auch überfälliger
schritt
trotzdem bleiben sie mit diesem gesetz
leider leider hinter dem zurück was
eigentlich notwendig wäre wenn
sorgfaltspflicht nur für die direkten
zulieferunternehmen gelten dann bleiburg
bei vielen komplexeren produktion ein
großteil der lieferkette außen vor
obwohl wir wissen dass die gravierendste
ausbeutung oft am anfang der lieferkette
stattfindet auf plantagen auch mit blick
auf den anwendungsbereich um den
umweltschutz bleibt ihr gesetz hinter
den erwartungen zurück
das größte versäumnis ist aber die
fehlende zivilrechtliche haftung die vor
allem der kanzlerin ein dorn im auge war
damit fehlt den menschen die unter
ausbeutung oder umweltzerstörung leiden
die möglichkeit besser vor gericht
dagegen vorzugehen
aber nur wenn betroffene eine echte
möglichkeit zur klage haben kann ein
solches gesetz seine volle wirksamkeit
entfalten wie wir kolleginnen und
kollegen von der koalition sie haben
noch die möglichkeit diese fehler zu
korrigieren
dafür müssen sie einfach nur unseren
vier gesetzänderung hier im plenum
gleich zustimmen die meisten menschen
und immer mehr unternehmen haben längst
erkannt für eine zukunftsfähige
wirtschaft brauchen wir klare regeln zur
einhaltung der menschenrechte und zum
schutz der umwelt
dabei ist dieses gesetz ein wichtiger
schritt und deshalb stimmen wir trotz
der schwächen als grüne
bundestagsfraktion heute zu aber es darf
mein einstieg sein und wir werden nicht
locker lassen und wir werden unsere
änderungsvorschläge zu diesem gesetz
nicht in der schublade verschwinden
lassen
wenn herr kommissar ein das einen
aufschlag für eine eu-weite regelung
machen wird wollen wir diese und auch
alle weiteren möglichkeiten nutzen damit
es endlich ein echtes lieferketten
gesetz mit zivilrechtliche haftung gibt
damit menschenrechte und klimaschutz die
bedeutung bekommen die sie verdienen
vielen dank also jetzt der bruder hat es
noch mal gesagt das gesetz würde auch
besser gehen die grünen haben auch
änderungsanträge aber es ist ein schritt
in die richtige richtung deswegen werden
die bündnisgrünen zustimmen
der nächste regen kommt von der spd
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
in unserem grundgesetz in artikel 1
steht das unverletzlichen und
unveräußerlichen menschenrechte die
grundlage jeder menschlichen
gemeinschaft des friedens und der
gerechtigkeit in der welt sind und den
unternehmen die sich daran halten
die entlang ihrer lieferketten
menschenrechtsverletzungen ausbeutung
bekämpfen und verhindern
für die ändert sich nichts dies ihnen
übrigens auch oft wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich ist also keine mehr nur zu
sagen wenn man ausbeute wenn man nicht
so genau hinschaut dann kann man sein
geschäft machen
denn diejenigen die eben nicht zu
hingeschaut haben die müssen jetzt
hinschauen müssen sich kümmern ist das
zu viel verlangt meine nein
david wesley ist der exekutiv korrektur
der welternährungsprogramms der
vereinten nationen ich konnte den öfters
treffen und sprechen und seine berichte
über hungerkatastrophen über für ihn das
wasser über instabilität die haben mich
so sehr berührt dass ich mich frage was
die größere katastrophe ist das elend in
der menschen leben müssen oder die
gleichgültigkeit im hinblick auf
menschenrechte in manchen chefetagen von
nun an heißt es
hinschauen sich kümmern anteil haben
abhilfe schaffen ein
beschwerdemanagement aufbau im wahrsten
sinne sich bemühen wer das aber nicht
tut dem drohen empfindliche strafen
ich danke allen die an diesem gesetz
mitglieder haben die das ermöglicht
haben die heute diesem gesetz zustimmen
allen voran den zwei freunden auf der
regierungsbank es sind zwei nicht drei
ich danke der ersten krise der bärbel
kofler die das in den koalitionsvertrag
eingebracht hatte erst den tag konnte
katja mast und alle die beteiligt waren
vielen vielen dank dafür all diejenigen
die das verhindert haben
und erkämpft haben mit viel engagement
bekämpft haben denn wünsche ich dass es
sich mehr mit diesem gleichen engagement
für die menschenrechte einsetzen und ich
wünsche ihnen dass sie irgendwann sich
ihren frieden machen wir beschließen
heute schärfste lieferketten gesetz der
welt und es wird eine richtschnur sein
für ein europäisches liefer kennen
gesetz bildern
ja und das kind das lieferketten gesetz
was sie verabschiedet werden soll sieht
vor dass kinder und zwangsarbeit sowie
in unsere arbeitsbedingungen ebenso
eingedämmt werden sollen wie
umweltzerstörung bei der produktion die
unternehmen sollen zur achtung
entsprechende standards verpflichtete
werden hermann gröhe
für die cdu ihre kollegen freier handel
muss fairer handel werden damit er allen
menschen zugute kommt das ist die
überzeugung christlicher demokrat und
christlich sozialer und deswegen ist die
beschlussfassung heute eines
lieferketten gesetzt ein großer
fortschritt
es ist ein stück internationalisierung
der prinzipien der sozialen
marktwirtschaft denn auch die soziale
marktwirtschaft kennt einen
verbindlichen rahmen für
unternehmerische verantwortung kein
appell an freiwillige beachtung
notwendiger regelung sondern ein
zusammenhang von sozialstaatlichkeit und
wirtschaftlicher freiheit und dies ist
kein wettbewerbsnachteil sondern
nachgewiesenermaßen seit jahrzehnten ein
wettbewerbsvorteil für dieses land und
deswegen verbindliche regeln und gerade
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer die
sich in eindrucksvoller weise um die
beachtung von menschenrechten bemühen in
ihren sorgfaltspflichten haben immer
wieder gesagt wir brauchen
verbindlichkeit wegschauen darf kein
vorteil sein
meine damen und herren ich will aber
auch etwas sagen zu den
parlamentarischen beratungen und manchen
gerüchten entgegentreten
dieses gesetz verlässt dieses
parlamentarische verfahren wirksamer und
stärker für die menschenrechte und
zugleich rechtssicher und umsetzbarer
für die beteiligte wirtschaft es ist
eben falsch da ständig 1 gegen kazan
einzulesen
nein wir brauchen beides wir weiter den
anwendungsbereich aus das ist gut so
auch auf ausländischen selbstständige
tochtergesellschaften einer bestimmten
größenordnung das ist eine ausweitung
die einbeziehung beherrscht der deutsche
töchter in den eigenen geschäftsbetrieb
bereich ist eine stärkung und
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich sorgen
ernst genommen wenn uns menschen befragt
haben
wie geht ihr mit dem grundsatz dass
unmögliches nicht verlangt werden darf
um wenn ein staat wie die volksrepublik
china keine gewerkschaften zu lässt dann
ist natürlich klar dass das kein
unternehmen ändern kann und dann ist es
auch richtig dass wir explizit ins
gesetz aufgenommen haben dass solche
dinge oder auch die nicht für
nachverfolgbarkeit von ursprungs für
produkt natürlich beachtung finden
müssen
das waren uns wichtige anliegen insofern
weiß ich auch den vorwurf zurück denen
die hier den unternehmen zugehört haben
nehmen es mit menschenrechtlich ernst
wir brauchen ein gesetz das vernünftige
handelsbeziehung und achtung der
menschenrechte gemeinsam stark meine
damen meine herren und das ist uns
gelungen und darauf können wir auch
stolz sein ich möchte sagen diese
rechtssicherheit nehmen wir ernst sorgen
nehmen wir ernst ich sage gleichzeitig
ungerechtfertigte pauschalkritik an
diesem gesetz weisen wir zurück wer
erklärt die herkunftsgeschichte eines
jeden bleistift im büro müsse
umfangreich dokumentiert werden der sagt
bewusst die unwahrheit das weisen wir an
dieser stelle genauso deutlich zurück ja
dieses gesetzes eine gute blaupause für
die eu und es ist vor allen dingen ein
anlass auch für uns und darauf werden
wir auch als parlament achten müssen
dass der staat auch mit
beratungsangeboten mit handreichungen
wie sie ausdrücklich das gesetz nennt
diesen prozess unterstützt insofern
bleiben beide die politik und die
wirtschaft weiterhin gefordert mit
diesem gesetz gehen wir einen richtigen
einen wichtigen schritt auf diesem weg
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
der lange wurde gestritten um das
lieferketten gesetzt jetzt geht auf
einmal alles ganz schnell noch zwei
rednerinnen und redner hier in der
debatte und dann gibt es hier
die abstimmung zunächst bärbel kofler
für die es bringt die kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich stehe heute hier auch als
menschenrechtsbeauftragten ich sage sehr
deutlich dieses dieser tag ist ein guter
tag für die menschenrechte und das
lieferketten gesetzt so leistet einen
wichtigen beitrag zur einhaltung der
menschenrechte weltweit
es ist ein paradigmenwechsel es reicht
nicht mehr aus freiwillig anzugeben man
würde standards beachten und wegzusehen
wenn die gesundheit von menschen
gefährdet wird die zukunft von kindern
zerstört wird und menschen unter
arbeitsbedingungen schuften müssen die
sie kaputt machen und nicht ausreichend
sich selbst oder ihre familie zu
ernähren oder eine zukunft zu entwickeln
das ist vorbei und es ist im inhalt viel
positives erreicht worden an der stelle
auch der dank an alle bericht erstattet
die dafür gekämpft haben
ich nenne für meine fraktion während
wird vor der sich sehr sehr stark
eingesetzt hat ein wichtiger punkt in
der debatte ist entlang der lieferkette
ich muss für mich selbst um standards
sagen ich muss es für meinen unmittelbar
zulieferer tun und ich muss es aber auch
für die mittelbaren diese zulieferer tun
wenn kenntnis antwort und kenntnis wird
sehr leicht erlaubt durch seriöse
berichte von
nichtregierungsorganisationen zum
beispiel wird kenntnis er sein also
sorgfaltspflicht risikoanalyse geht
entlang der gesamten lieferkette
und selbstverständlich gilt der zugang
zu effektiven rechtsschutz ist ein
grundlegendes unverzichtbares prinzip
einer rechtsstaatlichen ordnung das gilt
auch für alle denen schaden zugefügt
wird wir erleichtern diesen zugang durch
die prozessstandschaft minister hat es
ausgeführt
aber auch dort wo das haftungsrecht
unklarheiten offen lässt wird eines klar
mit diesem gesetz in zukunft müssen
sorgfaltspflichten beachtet werden dass
es ein sehr sehr wichtiges prinzip wir
haben einen bußgeldkatalog und
behördliche kontrolle
das heißt und das ist auch in der
anhörung klargeworden das gesetz hat
zähne und bis das gesetz gilt in der
gesamten lieferkette und es lässt
niemanden aus der pflicht und das ist
von entscheidender bedeutung
ich bitte sie deshalb alle noch einmal
hier um die zustimmung zu diesem gesetz
und lassen sie mich zum schluss auch
noch mal danken allen die mitgewirkt
haben an diesem gesetz ich denke aber
von kollegen aber bitte nicht alle
einzeln aufzuhellen nicht alle mediziner
abgelaufen ist herr präsident fühlen
sich offensichtlich alle eingeschlossen
aber der letzte satz ich glaube weil der
kollege sascha raabe gestern geburtstag
hatte können wir dieses gesetz im auch
nachträglich noch zum
geburtstagsgeschenk machen
die neuen regeln sollen ab anfang 2009
20 greifen allerdings nur für firmen mit
mehr als 3000 beschäftigte davon gibt es
zurzeit rund 600 ab 2024 gelten sie dann
auch für firmen mit mehr als 1000
beschäftigte weitere 2900 unternehmen
kommen hinzu
zum vergleich in frankreich gilt das
bislang weitestgehende gesetz für
menschenrechtliche sorgfaltspflichten
erst ab einer schwelle von 5000
beschäftigte der letzte redner kommt von
der cdu/csu thomas heimann
leider haben wir noch eine sehr kurze
redezeit für dieses doch so wichtige
gesetz vereinbart
und deswegen haben wir uns etwas
aufgeteilt oder ich würde gerne zu den
vorwürfen etwas sagen die
unberechtigterweise auch hier geäußert
worden
und ich sage das nicht nur als mitglied
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion sondern
ich sage dass der kronenberg weil ich
genau so unternehmer seit 30 jahren bin
wie sie ich finde selbstverständlich
sind menschenrechte auch aufgabe der
wirtschaft und nicht nur des staates und
ich habe mich um ihre rede ehrlich
gesagt geärgert weil das dem ansehen der
sozialen marktwirtschaft schade wenn wir
sagen das ist alles nur eine staatliche
aufgabe
und der springer aber es ihn gesagt
haben ist zynisch dass ich gar nicht
wusste was ich sagen kann sie sind
diejenigen die hier vier jahre lang
gesagt haben wir sollen die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit kirsten und
jetzt sagen sie das gesetz oder wenig
machen weil der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit machen sollen
also ehrlich gesagt habe bleiben wir
doch wenigstens konsistent und auch ihr
vorwurf das sei eine deutsche idee ist
absurd es ist eine idee der von ihr sind
vereinten nationen vor zehn jahren
geboren ist und wir wirken daran wie
andere länder mit und auch andere länder
vor uns haben entsprechende gesetze
gemacht und ich würde gerne zu der
wirksamkeit etwas noch sagen das
entscheidende das entscheidende der herr
kollege heime gestand inzwischen frage
ja ja herr kollege heilmann tiere
bundestagspräsident ich habe ja keine
letzte räte mein letztes zwischenfrage
wird das seien jetzt nach 19 jahren als
entwicklungs politikern und sie haben zu
recht gesagt herr einmal was die
wirtschaft angeht diejenigen die sagen
dass das gesetz quasi ja den unternehmen
auferlegen würde dinge zu tun die
regierung machen müsste das sind die
gleichen die haben wir verhindern dass
bei uhr handelsabkommen auch nicht diese
nachhaltigkeit kapiteln verbindlich sind
und ich glaube das ist eigentlich ganz
wichtig und ich möchte einen der stelle
einfach nur sagen genauso wie viele hier
die das 19 jahre fort gesehen haben
wenn man sieht dass kinder in löcher
runter gelassen werden um diamanten zu
klopfen
das elend was man gesehen hat ich bin
ich bin wirklich glücklich dass wir
heute diesen historischen schritt machen
ich danke dort allen wir haben uns die
0,7 oder einzig erreicht wir haben das
lieferketten gesetz erreicht es wie
gesagt das ist mir ja die schönste
geburtstagsgeschenk schönste
abschiedsgeschenk und ich wünsche allen
auch nachfolgerinnen und nachfolgern
dass das gesetz damit leben erfüllt wird
und wir wirklich heute den ersten
schritt machen in eine welt ohne
ausbeutung und hunger und in dem sinne
vielen dank für die zusammenarbeit das
war mein letztes sein letzter satz
als letztes wort ich bedanke mich bei
allen kolleginnen und kollegen für die
freundschaftliche gute zusammenarbeit
und wünscht dem parlament eine gute
zukunft lang
vorweg ich glaube ich spreche im namen
nahezu aller mitglieder des hauses das
ob ich auch ihnen für die 19 jahre und
die engagement für die menschenrechte
danken kann
ich habe die frage doch gar nicht
beantwortet ich bin allerdings anderer
meinung als sie das ist nicht der erste
schritt den wir tun aber es darf und
wird ganz gewiss auch nicht der letzte
sein
1859 hat preußen die buchprüfung pflicht
eingeführt weil man damals zu der
erkenntnis kamen das richtige bilanzen
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe und
nicht nur eine verpflichtung
aber das war auch sehr wirksam aber wir
haben bis wir zu unserem heutigen
wirtschaftsprüfungs recht gekommen sind
dass die wir bei wirecard gesehen haben
wir noch lücken hat nach wie vor diese
gesetzliche aufgabe ich weiß nicht wie
oft in der welt modifiziert und
verbessert und so werden wir ganz sicher
diese schwierige aufgabe menschenrechte
überall in der welt zur wertung zu
kommen werden wir noch ganz oft und auch
ganz sicher nicht nur im deutschen
bundestag nachbessern müssen doch das
ist teil dieser aufgabe und bin ich das
sagen darf wie wir hören besser zeit wir
haben gesagt eigentlich sei auch
verpflichtet ist stimmt leider und ich
sagen ist leider nicht weil die un vor
zehn jahren aus meiner sicht den fehler
begangen hat ist an mitarbeiter zahlen
festzumachen und nicht an umsatz was
nicht persönlich für richtig gehalten
hatte zurück zu den einwänden drucker
ich wollte ihnen noch mal sagen es
stimmt einfach nicht was sie sagen
ich selber bin seit zwölf jahren
engagiert und einer in giro wir haben
auch mit endlos viel geredet aber es ist
schon wichtig und auch der
wirtschaftsflügel dass ein gesetz
handhabbar und praktisch ist und da gab
es dinge die muss man auch verstehen
weil so schafft man einen
gesellschaftlichen konsens und dann
miteinander und jetzt steht ja der
wirtschaftsflügel auch hinter dem gesetz
das sie selber ja als vielleicht noch
nicht wirksam genug aber immer
als wirksam bezeichnet haben meine
redezeit ist zuende deswegen möchte ich
da abschied ich persönlich bin als
unternehmer stolz als mitglied dieser
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion und als
jemand der seit zwölf jahren für die
älteste kinderrechtsorganisation der
welt setzte john arbeitet bin ich auch
stolz dass wir heute diesen meilenstein
verabschieden können und ich freue mich
über jeden und jede die heute zuständen
vielen dank
[Applaus]